hindsight is of course 20/20 but now I
haven't practiced law for over 10 years
there is so much that I would have done
differently in law school if I had known
then what I know now so here's a list of
things that I would have done
differently if I had to do law school
all over again
please learn from my mistakes okay so
what would I do differently if I had to
do law school all over again well the
first thing that I would do is I would
spend way less time preparing for class
in law school class participation
usually counts for almost nothing at
best it counts for maybe five or ten
percent of your grade there's there's
almost no class participation preparing
for class is a time suck it doesn't help
you on the final exam
your job is not to understand everything
by the time you get to class if your
professor is doing their job they will
help you understand it when you get to
class I know the idea of getting
cold-called in class is so scary and
nobody wants to look dumb in front of
their classmates but it will not matter
how hard you prepare for class even if
you do get called on the professor
creates their questions in a way that no
one could possibly answer all of them if
you do the reading and preferably you
use our flipped case method the link for
that is down below then you'll be
prepared enough for class but you should
prepare for class in an efficient way
don't obsess about getting everything
perfect beforehand understand by that by
the time you start studying for finals
you will have forgotten everything that
you did to prepare for class I would
have put in the absolute minimum to
prepare for class and would have used
class time to refine my thinking and
work on my outline I would have taken
the time I used to spend preparing for
class and I would have started preparing
for finals sooner because it's the
finals where you get your grade not
preparing for class so in retrospect I
would have spent so much less time
obsessing over every nuance in my new
sha in the case and preparing for class
on the odd chance that I got called on
by the professor and I just would have
prepared for finals instead also I even
if your class does have participation
points you don't have to rely on the
only interaction of your professor being
when you're cold called you should ask
questions of your professor when you
have legitimate questions and on top of
that you should go to office hours and
talk to your professor in a less formal
environment these are all ways that you
can raise your participation grade while
also bettering your understanding of the
case material itself the next thing that
I would have done differently is I would
have started taking practice tests way
earlier we talked about this a lot at
legal eagle practice tests are one of
the most important things you can do to
get better grades in law school writing
a law school exam is unlike any other
kind of writing that's why English
majors have such a hard time with law
school they more than anyone else have
to undo the habits that they learned in
college a lot of the things that they
learn in terms of good writing are
actually bad for writing quickly and
clearly on a law school exam in fact
that's why at legal eagle we created a
master class specifically teaching
people how to think like a lawyer and
write like a lawyer on a final exam I
would have started taking practice tests
at least halfway through the semester if
not sooner I know that sounds crazy but
it is never too early to start taking
practice tests and it is guaranteed to
get you better grades the next thing I
would have done in law school is I would
have taken a course on how to write law
school final exams earlier because law
school final exams are so unusual and
because your law school won't teach you
the skill it is so important to learn
what a law school final exam looks like
and how you're supposed to write them
odds are if you took the LSAT you
probably took some courses on how to
answer the questions whether it is a
logic game or reading comprehension
there's so much to learn that's specific
to the LSAT that you probably had no
frame of reference for in college the
LSAT is not like the SAT and it's
certainly not like you're your college
classes and it's the same way when you
get to law school itself law school
final exams are unlike any other test in
any other field that any other
graduate or professional school they are
issue spotting exams where you have to
actually use the law itself just showing
the professor that you know know the law
is not enough you have to apply it there
is a method and a science to breaking
down issue spotting essays and writing
an A exam every single time and it has
very little to do with how much law you
actually know the person that knows less
law but more about how to write the
essay is gonna get a better grade than
the person that knows more of the law
and memorized more of the facts in class
discussion but doesn't actually know how
to spot the issues and how to write them
down
on the final exam like the LSAT
answering law school issue spotters is a
skill and you can get better at any
skill you can also learn how to do that
particular skill there are strategies
that you can use to get better over time
and the better you get at final exams
the better your grades will be at the
end of the year the next tip the next
thing I would have done differently in
law school is I would have lived much
much closer to campus when I went to law
school
I actually didn't live that far away but
the law school was on one end of the
campus and I lived on the other end of
campus so it took me probably about 45
minutes to walk each way to and from
class like because it was a very large
campus so even though I was within
walking distance of the law school it
still took 45 minutes each way or an
hour and a half each day out of my day
to walk to and from class and that's
only if I went to the law school once a
day if I went twice then that's three
hours that I lost it's even worse for
the people that have to commute to
school during that commuting time you
can't study it's just dead time and and
worse it's it's probably stressing you
out driving is no fun when you're on a
deadline one of the worst things you can
do is live so far away from campus that
you have to drive commuting is is just
the worst it's time that you can't study
and it's probably pretty stressful
because driving on a deadline just tends
to be very stressful and it's probably
exhausting too so if you're commuting
to class that is hours a day where you
can't study and it's just making you
more tired so it's going to prevent you
from studying later on in a day often if
you live very close to campus there's no
doubt that the rent costs are going to
be more but at the same time you can
probably forego the cost of owning a car
having to insure it having to pay gas so
even though the rent might be more it
might actually save you money in the
long run and frankly if you're going to
law school full time you're probably
already on the hook for spending at
least a hundred thousand dollars so
spending slightly more to avoid
commuting is completely worth it
especially if you can turn the time that
you would otherwise commute to class
into studying time where you can get
better grades that will result in a
better higher-paying job down the line
that's what law school is all about
anyway so if I had to do it all over
again I would have lived as close to the
law school as possible so that I could
just get up walk across the street and
then go to law school without even
thinking about it I would have saved so
much time I would have been far less
tired and I would have been able to
study more and better the the next thing
that I would have done differently I
would have trusted the professor much
less in law school it's so easy to get
in this mindset where your professor is
just infallible and they are giving you
the law as it exists straight from a
Platonic ideal but the thing is your
first year lost subjects they seemed
really hard when you're in it but
they're really not when you start
practicing you realize just how
oversimplified everything is and
different law professors have completely
different ways of communicating those
subjects to students and there is no
universal conception of the law so it's
not like your professor can give you the
law as you know given by Moses and the
tablet server or whatever I would have
worried much less about when the
professor said conflicting things when
the professor said confusing things a
lot of what you learn in law school is
just confusing it's complicated when
you're in it for the first time and you
have no frame of reference I wouldn't
really have worried when the professor
said things that seemed to
contradict each other or said some
conception of the law that seemed
confusing at the time law professors
often make things worse sometimes they
do things to intentionally obfuscate so
that they can generate conversation in
the class remember that the Socratic
method exists not for the benefit of
students but for the benefit of the
professor to make it interesting for
them when they're lecturing the Socratic
method is not a good way to teach the
law it's just simply the historical way
that we've used it for 150 years so I
wouldn't have worried as much in when
the classroom discussion is confusing I
wouldn't have worried when the professor
seemed to make it even more complicated
now I know that almost everything that
is discussed in a 1l class is just it's
settled law especially when you get into
a particular state sometimes a state can
vary with a different state in terms of
law but for the most part all of the
questions that you deal with in a
first-year class are completely settled
it's only at the very extreme margins
where there's much controversy but
that's not what first-year classes test
if the professor created more confusion
in class I simply would have ignored the
professor knowing that I could figure
things out later on when I went back to
my commercial supplements and worked on
my outline or if I looked up the cases
on Westlaw knowing what I know now about
the law it would have made life so much
easier because I would have realized
that the professor is not the best
source of the law and I could always go
back and get the black letter law from
my my outlines and supplements and
speaking of which if you want additional
tips on how to reveal all the mysteries
of law school and how to crush your next
law school exam click the link below for
our guide on Law School and please
subscribe to our Channel we come out
with new tips on how to crush law school
all the time and I'll see you next time
here at legal legal please learn from my
mistakes there's no reason that you
should go through the same kind of crap
that I have
started taking practice than that to
start taking practice tests and it is
and it has very little to do with
actually be close to campus